dans le cadre de ses déplacements du
président de la république je peux avoir
des contacts sur le terrain avec les
services de l'elysée comme la chaufferie
du cabinet le j'espère voir le
commandement militaire
or la question du 1er mai 2018
j'ai ainsi rencontré l'ancien adjoint au
chef de cabinet du président de la
république monsieur ben alla alexandre
une dizaine de fois dans le cadre de
dispositifs prévus par note de service
ces services n'ont pas soulever de
difficultés particulières pour moi
autorités civiles à la direction de
l'ordre public et de la circulation
monsieur benalla était l'adjoint au chef
du cabinet du président de la république
il était en charge de l'organisation et
de la coordination des services sur les
déplacements du président sur plusieurs
aspects comme la sécurité générale où le
protocole en tant que chef adjoint de
cabinet monsieur ben alors exprimé les
souhaits et les demandes de la
présidence de la république
je vous précise que je n'entretiens que
des relations professionnelles avec
monsieur ban à la je ne n'ai jamais vu
en dehors d'un dispositif de service
d'ordre prévu par note de service
je vous vois monsieur benalla je
l'appelle monsieur benalla ce dernier
m'appelle commissaire et me vouvoie je
n'ai pas le numéro de téléphone de
monsieur ben alla et je n'ai aucune
relation de copinage ou d'amitié avec
monsieur benalla jeunes entretien avec
lui que des relations strictement
professionnel dans le cadre de service
d'ordre prévu par une note de service
je vais maintenant est à votre
disposition monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs pour répondre à
vos questions
je vous précise simplement comme vous
l'avez fait monsieur le président je
vous en remercie que je ne pourrais pas
répondre aux questions portant sur
l'effet du 18 et du 18 juillet faits
pour lesquels je suis mis en examen dans
cette affaire je vous dirais simplement
que dans cette affaire
j'estime n'avoir commis aucune faute de
nature pénale
et je me considère comme un
fonctionnaire de police loyal et honnête
et